COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I hope some gaming nomads find
their way back to performance.
Should we have stopped
to ask for directions?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Nomad Socialite was a
new geolocation game
where players traveled
all around the world
to rack up points, catch
the latest in urban events,
and meet a whole community,
all at the same time.
The game has been a hit,
but their event producers
noticed that the
analytics system-- which
was powered by Datastore--
started to slow significantly
when updating.
See, any time you're trying
to store analytics data
in Datastore, I can
tell you the problem
without even
checking-- contention.
Simply put, Datastore
contention occurs
when a single entity or entity
group is updated too rapidly.
Once contention
gets high enough,
Datastore will queue concurrent
requests to wait their turn.
But if the number of edits
on an entity is too high,
things will eventually slow
down as the requests stack up,
until timeout errors are thrown.
Specifically, we
see this most often
when using Datastore
for things like counting
the number of views to
a page on your site.
Or, in the case of
Nomad Socialite,
updating the analytics
data for an event
meant keeping a running count of
the number of users logged in,
and all of their
related data sets.
Now, when this happens, there's
lots of ways to address it,
but the simplest
might be sharding.
Sharding effectively
duplicates an entity,
and uses a version of
manual load balancing
to write updates to
the clones instead
of all to the same item.
The result is that each clone is
partially updated with respect
to your data set.
When you read from the sharded
set, you fetch all copies
and sum them together
on the client.
You'll end up with
the same result,
but with less contention.
To show the
performance difference,
we wrote a small test using the
Artillery framework in order
to simulate their user base.
The graph here shows
pretty much what
we expected-- our sharded
version outperforms
its regular counterpart.
Since sharding distributes
the work across more entities,
the contention is lower,
thus performance is better.
If you're interested in
how to set up sharding,
or some other options
in case sharding
doesn't suit your
needs, check out
the article linked in
the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas
content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]